what we're going to do in this video is
start thinking about the position of an
object traveling in one dimension and to
get our bearings there i'm going to
introduce a few ideas
so the first idea is that of
displacement
so you might use that word in everyday
language and it literally means your
change in position
your change
in
position
now a related idea that sometimes gets
confused with displacement is the notion
of distance
traveled
and you might say well doesn't that
isn't that just the same thing as change
in position and you will see shortly no
it isn't always the same thing the
distance traveled this is the total
length of path total
length
of path
so what are we talking about well let's
say and we're going to introduce a
little bit of calculus now let's say
that we have a particle's velocity
function
and so let's say our velocity as a
function of time
is equal to 5 minus t
now this is a one-dimensional velocity
function let's say it's just telling us
our velocity in the horizontal direction
and oftentimes when something's one
dimension people forget well that 2 can
be a vector quantity in fact this
velocity is a vector quantity because
you could think of it if it's positive
it's moving to the right and if it's
negative it's moving to the left so it
has a direction and so sometimes you
will see a vector quantity like this
have a little arrow on it or
you will see it bolded or you will see
it bolded like that i like to write an
arrow in it although that's not always
the convention used in different classes
now let's plot what this velocity
function actually looks like and i did
that ahead of time
so you can see here time equals zero
let's say time is in seconds and our
velocity is in meters per second so this
is meters per second right over here and
this is seconds in this axis
at exactly time zero this object is
traveling at five meters per second and
we could say to the right it has a
velocity of positive 5 meters per second
but then it keeps decelerating at a
constant rate so 5 seconds into it right
at 5 seconds the particle has no
velocity and then it starts having
negative velocity which you could mean
you could interpret as moving to the
left so let's think about a few things
first let's think about what is the
displacement
over the first five seconds over
first
five
seconds
well we've seen already multiple times
if you want to find the change in
quantity you can take the integral of
the rate function of it and so velocity
is actually the rate of displacement is
one way to think about it so
displacement over the first five seconds
we could take the integral from zero to
5
0 to 5 of our velocity function
of our velocity function
just like that
and we can even calculate this really
fast that would just be this area
right over here which we could just use
a little bit of geometry this is a five
by five triangle so five times five is
twenty-five times one-half remember area
of a triangle is one-half base times
height so this is going to be
12.5 and let's see this is going to be
meters per second times seconds so 12.5
meters so that's the change in position
for that particle over the first five
seconds
wherever it started it's now going to be
12.5 meters to the right of it assuming
that positive is to the right
now what about over
over the first
10 seconds now this gets interesting and
i encourage you to pause your video and
think about it what would be the
displacement over the first 10 seconds
well we would just do the same thing the
integral from
0 to 10
of our velocity function our one
dimensional velocity function
d
t
and so that would be the area from here
all the way to right over there so this
entire area
but you might appreciate when when
you're taking a definite integral if we
are below the t-axis and above the
function like this this is going to be
negative area and in fact this area and
this area are going to exactly cancel
out and you're going to get
0 meters
now you might be saying how can that be
after 10 seconds how do we how why is
our displacement only zero meters this
particle has been moving the entire time
well remember what's going on
the first five seconds it's moving to
the right it's decelerating the whole
time and then right at five seconds it
has gone 12.5 meters to the right
but then it starts its velocity starts
becoming negative and the particle
starts moving to the left and so over
the next five seconds it actually moves
12.5 meters to the left and then these
two things net out
so the particle has gone over 10 seconds
12.5 meters to the right and then 12.5
meters to the left and so its change in
position is zero meters it has not
changed
now you might start you might start to
be appreciating what the difference
between displacement and distance
traveled is
so distance if you're talking about your
total length of path you don't care as
much about direction and so instead of
thinking about velocity what we would do
is think about speed and speed
is you could view
in this case especially in this one
dimensional case this is equal to the
absolute value of
velocity
later on when we do multiple dimensions
it would be the magnitude of the
velocity function which is what the
absolute function
which is what the absolute value
function does in one dimension
so what would this look like if we
plotted it
well the absolute value of the velocity
function would just look like that
and so if you want the distance you
would find the approach the distance
traveled i should say you would find the
integral over the appropriate change in
time of the speed function right over
here which we have graphed so notice if
we want the distance traveled
so i'll just say i'll write it out
distance
traveled
over
first five seconds
first five seconds what would it be well
it would be the integral from zero to
five of the absolute value of our
velocity function which is you could
just view it as our speed function right
over here dt and so it would be this
area which we already know to be 12.5
meters
so for the first five seconds your
distance and displacement are consistent
well that's because you have in this
case the velocity function is positive
so the absolute value of it is still
going to be positive but if you think
about
over
the first 10 seconds your distance
10
seconds what is it going to be pause the
video and try to think about it
well that's going to be the integral
from 0 to 10 of the absolute value of
our velocity function
which is going to be equal to what well
it's going to be this area plus this
area right over here
so
plus this area right over here and so
this is going to be 5 times 5 times 1
half plus 5 times 5 times one half which
is going to be 25
meters
the particle has gone 12.5 meters to the
right and then it goes back 12.5 meters
to the left
your displacement your net change in
position is zero but the total length of
path traveled is 25 meters